the s p 500 technically fell into a
correction on monday meaning the market
fell by at least 10 percent from its
last high but then we pulled out and
actually closed higher if you've been
watching the stock market to tell you
what's happening you're looking in the
wrong place it's all about bonds i'm
going to explain why the stock market
pulled back how the federal reserve is
involved and what this all means for the
economy and the markets going forward
after the s p 500 touched correction
territory this week everybody wants to
know what happened right the russell
2000 was down 20 from its last record
high and the nasdaq is heading in that
direction too in fact it's having its
worst start to a year since 2008 this is
all about the federal reserve and u.s
interest rates
so late last year the federal reserve
announced it was ending quantitative
easing and beginning quantitative
tightening then on wednesday fed chair
jerome powell doubled down and made it
clear the fed is going full steam ahead
the economy no longer needs this
this
highly accommodative policy that we put
in place so
it's time to stop asset purchases first
and then at the appropriate time
start to shrink the balance sheet at its
december meeting the fed used the term
balance sheet 28 times and we learned
that from the minutes that came out
january 5th that matters because when
the fed shrinks its balance sheet it's
literally pulling money out of the
economy through quantitative easing the
fed has been pushing 120 billion dollars
out into the markets every single month
think about it like this imagine if your
parents have been giving you a thousand
dollars every month in a savings account
and then one day out of the blue they
call you and they say listen the gravy
train's over in three months we're not
putting that thousand dollars a month in
your bank account anymore well
you probably make some life changes
right well that's what's happening with
the stock market
stock traders and investors are making
some life changes with the way they
evaluate stocks are these companies
still worth their lofty valuations if
the fed isn't pumping 120 billion
dollars a month out into the economy the
fed is getting ready to raise u.s
interest rates and that means the cost
of money is going up when the fed raises
rates that makes it more expensive to
borrow it also makes it more attractive
to save now that influences every market
across the board because it changes how
investors value assets if the fed is
going to raise interest rates three
times this year that's going to make it
a lot more difficult and expensive for
companies that aren't currently
generating a profit to be successful and
about one in five large u.s companies
aren't generating a profit right now or
even making enough money to pay off
their debt so a lot of traders out there
are saying yeah yeah yeah we've seen
this before they remember in 2018 when
the fed was raising rates and said they
were going to keep raising rates on
automatic pilot then the market sold off
and the fed reversed course and even cut
interest rates in 2019. well the fed's
gonna have a lot harder time doing that
with inflation at seven percent like it
was in december at least that's what
annetta markowska and a number of other
prominent market watchers think they
think the fed might be stuck with
inflation rising this fast they're not
going to be able to pull back and bail
investors in the market out but watch
out for retail individual investors have
shown they love to buy the dip it's not
about fundamentals for them they've
learned that if stock prices go down the
fed is going to step into the market one
way or another and make sure those stock
prices go right back up but if inflation
doesn't cool
the fed's hands may be tied the fed may
have to decide which is a bigger risk
runaway inflation or a plunging stock
market
what they choose could have huge
implications for the future of the
market and the economy as a whole if you
enjoyed this video hit the like button
and if you're interested in markets and
want to watch and learn more subscribe
to this channel to keep up with my
latest i believe it was president carter
aka jay-z who said i know this game got
valleys and peaks expectation for dips
for precipitation we stack chips
that's all for now see you next time